alors olivier vial qui est le président
de l'unis l'union nationale inter
universitaire qui le syndicat des
étudiants de droite bonsoir comment vous
réagissez l'ajustement à ce que est ce
que vous venez d'entendre est-ce que
vous pensez que les étudiants sont
désormais dépossédés de leur avenir
universitaire en partie c'est vrai qu'on
fait c'est une véritable occasions et on
aurait pu avoir un vrai débat sur la
sélection est un vrai une réflexion
transparent pour on dise aux étudiants
bac elle bat il faut faire pour avoir
tout pour entrer dans quelle filière qui
permettait aux étudiants d'avoir
toujours la main elle choisit rapidement
les la manière de fonctionner or
aujourd'hui on a créé parce que le giron
d'ordre sélection ils ont créé un vrai
système bureaucratique avec plein de
commissions qui vont se succéder pour au
final ne même pas sélectionné réellement
les étudiants et donc ont effectivement
un gâchis humain et financier que ça va
coûter très très cher pour finalement un
résultat qui fera très très mauvaise
olivier valent pas viable parmi les
annonces ya le rattachement des
étudiants à la sécurité sociale
jusqu'à présent c'était géré par des
mutuelles la mnef ou d'autres mutuelles
qui était proche à votre votre syndicat
comment vous réagissez à cet assaut
changement là aussi on surveille de près
mais là encore une demi mesure puisque
finalement on annonce que ont fait
cadeau de l'inscription des droits
d'inscriptions d'étudiants
sauf que dans le même temps leur reprend
un peu plus la moitié de la somme pour
un fonds dont on ne sait rien et donc
sais pas comment il va être gérée et a
priori il ya des vraies inquiétudes sur
des conflits d'intérêts possibles
il serait plus ou moins gérer comme les
tels les fonds de solidarité d'urgence
par des associés et par des responsables
associatifs étudiants
donc elle tue on est une vraie un vrai
point de vigilance parce que on est dans
quelque chose ou on invente une garantie
le gouvernement nous dit qui fait qui
fait un cadeau aux étudiantes de 110
euros
et dans le même temps il remonte une il
y prend de l'autre main 120 euros dans
la poche des étudiants
donc là il ya une manip
dont on ne voit pas bien l'intérêt n'est
qu' effectivement bas il fallait faire
plaisir à aux syndicats devenus
majoritaires la fage qui avait fait de
ce cheval de bataille un point de
négociation et donc c'est pour faire
plaisir à la phase qu'est la clape sans
doute la sélection ça qu'on soit on fera
un débat avec olivier vial sûr avec la
avec la fage file au fond et avec lui
neuf sur ces questions là juste vous
êtes bon un peu négatif sur 7 sur ces
annonces la fin de la paix b quand même
c'est pas mal non
oui sauf mais ce rythme beaucoup plus
soutenu et ça aurait pu être beaucoup
plus efficace puisque en fait
aujourd'hui on a par exemple 94 % des
bacheliers professionnels qui échoue à
l'université demain ils pourront
toujours s'inscrire à l'université
il aurait été beaucoup plus simple de le
redire quand on a un bac pro n'a pas
vocation à rentrer à l'université on a
vocation à faire d'autres filières ou à
trouver un emploi et donc au
gouvernement d'en pêtre des systèmes
pour vous aider à trouver un emploi
or on n'a pas fait ça pour éviter le mot
sélection et donc les bacheliers pros
peuvent continuer à part biais de
différentes commissions à rentrer à
l'université et au bout il y aura quand
même un échec et un échec massif
on est sur 94% des chèques en quatre ans
au lit elie olivier vial il ya des 500
ma dernière question elle est posée par
daniel au final il n'y a plus de place
dans les facs comment faire dit elle le
problème de l'a72 c'est l'ex de la
sélection est il vraiment le vrai
problème alors il ya effectivement une
mauvaise affectation d'espions ce que ce
qu'on ne sait pas c'est que l'année
dernière il y avait 130 mille places non
occupées dans les universités une très
mauvaise gestion des ressources humaines
est une très mauvaise gestion des places
l'année dernière 132 places non occupées
donc on n'a pas un problème de locaux on
n'a pas un problème de moyens on a un
problème d'orientation des étudiants et
d'orientation des moyens et pendant très
longtemps on n'a pas voulu regarder
comment on orientait les moyens et donc
on a créé des postes et les placements
des filières qu'ils n'ont aucun débouché
donc vous que les étudiants bouder et là
c'est là le vrai point noir cette
réforme c'est que cette réforme crée un
dispositif d'orientation en fin de
course
si un étudiant n'a aucun
aucune affectation il ya une commission
électorale qui va l'affecter dans des
filières où il ya de la place donc
l'orientation par défaut devient
finalement une orientation validée par
un recteur et ça c'est ce qui a plu
catastrophique parce que ce qu'il
fallait faire c'est réorienter les
moyens humains et financiers des
universités pour aller vers les filières
qui roule à venir faire des filières qui
sont demandées par les d'étudiants et
pas réaffecter les étudiants dans les
filières où il y aura de la place
merci encore et ça on a effectivement
d'étudiants qui vont se retrouver le
lait dans le bec dans l'eau mais en deux
langues deux chercheurs d'emploi merci
beaucoup olivier vial on l'a vu vous
êtes critique ça vous fait au moins un
point commun avec vos frères ennemis de
l'unef sur cette question merci d'avoir
été en direct avec nous d'un point de
vue sur figaro live